[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine football pour la première
fois de son histoire versailles s'est
qualifié pour les demi finales de la
coupe de france en battant bergerac aux
tirs au but retour sur cette rencontre
historique pour ce club de nationale 2
les qualifications que nous avons suivi
en immersion au rugby versailles pris
également cette discipline rcv s'est
imposé contre où il ce week-end en
championnat de fédérale 3 le résumé du
match dans ce magazine basket ce jeudi à
17 février les lycées à sainte-geneviève
et hoche de versailles vont s'affronter
sur un match qui s'annonce bouillant
dans une ambiance électrique coup de
projecteur dans ce set 8 sports active
suite
ils l'ont fait le fc versailles 78 et
brillamment qualifié pour les 1/2
finales de la coupe de france en
s'imposant mercredi dernier face à
bergerac à périgueux pourtant rien n'a
été simple pour le club yvelinois tout
avait bien commencé
les joueurs de la cité royale ouvre le
score à la 14e minute par inzaghi
diarrassouba magnifique but pour un
joueur qui n'a pas souvent l'occasion de
s'illustrer dans l'exercice 1 0 ce sera
le score à la pause mais les joueurs de
versailles se font peur et se font
égalisé à la 90e minute par bergerac un
but signé axel très sens à ce moment là
on s'est dit que ce serait très
compliqué d'aller chercher la victoire
est finalement les versailles
l'emportent 5 tirs au but à 4 dans
l'euphorie générale
après un tir au but manqué par mingoua
on écoute les réactions à la fin de
cette rencontre historique
c'est un match difficile en face à une
bonne équipe avec un socle solide
défensif on a réussi à déjouer ce plan
en marquant assez tôt
ça reste un avantage très important face
à ce genre d'équipé et mais on a manqué
justement de lucidité sur une ou deux
situations pour pouvoir tenir le score
jusqu'au bout les bons derrière les
garçons ont réussi à se concentrer et
s'approprier cette séance de pénalty dès
que le match il a fini j'ai dit le gars
on a pris un but mais la 4e minute ou
plus on savait sinon c'est une
possibilité on est parti en confiance
tout mon ami c'est penalty on a eu la
chance que un genre de bergerac tir sur
le poteau et ça nous assurait
aujourd'hui donc très content une
qualification en demi finale de coupe de
france est une grande première pour un
club yvelinois une belle récompense pour
les supporters versailles et qui avaient
fait le déplacement jusqu'à périgueux
pour soutenir les joueurs nous avons
suivi ce périple en immersion avec les
56 courageux présents mercredi dernier
au stade regardez
nous allons suivre le déplacement à des
supporters de versailles jusqu'à
périgueux pour le quart de finale entre
bergerac et versailles un périple de à
600 km et ils sont motivés
[Applaudissements]
venez on va les citernes
ouais
ça fait donc trois heures et demie que
les supporters versailles sont partis
depuis versailles avait coté à anthony
alors anthony comment ça se passe du
coup ce déplacement bah ça se passe
plutôt bien c'est une ambiance bon
enfant en jouer bon on vient à un moment
magnifique parce que des moments comme
ça on a envie de rap a peut-être pas plu
du tout on sait pas on espère qu'on en
verra d'autres mais faut profiter il
faut prendre à fond tout ce qu'on a là
là maintenant et en profiter un max en
trois ans en club ça fait ça vous fait
quoi de voir versailles à ce niveau là
la compétition j'ai déjà vécu une partie
parce que quand on a battu dijon une
fois en huitièmes de finale mais bon là
c'est un rêve là c'est vraiment quelque
chose de sensationnel et on va aller
voir loïc qui justement voilà les côtés
maintenant
alors loïc vous êtes supporter depuis
une dizaine d'année 1 c'est ça du club
de versailles bah j'ai mon fils qui a
commencé après j'ai été dirigeant et
puis là je me suis engagé avec les
copains en tant que vétéran donc voila
quoi et puis on supporte l'équipe et on
s'amuse on fait tous ont chanté voilà
quoi impeccable mais ça vous fait quoi
justement de voir versailles en quarts
de finale à un petit frisson quand même
les petits poils qui se hérissent sur le
bout des bras c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique et j'espère qu'on l'a
chicoter bergerac quand elle m'a dit
pourquoi il n'y a pas de raison vous
avez un petit pronostic ou pas pour pour
ce soir à moi je vois bien un petit 4 0
voire 04 ça serait mieux
04 est ce qu'on mettait l'ambiance en là
dans le bus là on sent que c'est ce que
vous mettez dans l'ambiance dans le bus
sans trop de bruit mes collègues l'aï
dit c'est trop bruyant l'ambiance allait
pas terrible envie
[Applaudissements]
on est arrivé à périgueux après sept
heures de route donc on n'est pas venu
pour rien on est venu pour marquer un
maximum de buts là aujourd'hui ya le roi
soleil qui avec nous il va peut nous
porter chance et on espère se qualifier
et récupérer le trône
[Musique]
après 14 minutes de jeu versailles ouvre
le score par inzaghi diarrassouba 1 0
pour les joueurs de la cité royale
[Musique]
au même moment explosion de joie devant
l'écran géant installé place du marché à
versailles
1 0 ce sera le score à la pause
c'est bien ça joue bien et ses buts a
fait beaucoup de bien hoa
et surtout ils défendent est très bien
entré bon pressing on arrivait à
faire un bloc plus forte je pense que on
a bien joué cette première mi temps et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la fête est gâchée à la 90e minute
at récent seule marque et égalise pour
bergerac
[Applaudissements]
les deux équipes vont devoir se
départager dans une terrible séance de
tirs au but il ne reste plus qu'une
chose c'est les avoirs aux penaltys ya
plus de ça je me tape tourné le dos là
un peu stressé quoi
[Applaudissements]
à versailles aussi et milliers de
supporters des joueurs de la cité royale
vont stresser jusqu'au bout font
après trois tirs au but réussis de
chaque côté à bergerac manque ce penalty
en tirant sur le poteau diouf lé marque
le but libérateur
pour la première fois de son histoire
versailles se qualifie pour les demi
finales de la coupe de france c'est une
grande fierté d'avoir un club qui fait
un tel exploit pour tous cette ville
c'est versailles c'est historique c'est
magique c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
le versailles club de nationale 2 sera
en demi finale de coupe de france la
belle aventure continue
ça y est c'est fait versailles 8 en demi
finale de la coupe de france ils
viennent de battre tirs au but bergerac
lyciens périgueux dans une ambiance
fantastique
tu connais des versailles ont justement
n'est allé rencontrer il s'en fout parce
qu ils communient avec les joueurs en ce
moment alors c'était comment ce match
fera comme vous voyez c'est la folie
on va voir comment les autres faut-il
porter
notre fidèle supporter at il ajouté
qu'est ce que je dis résultat victoire
tient victoire aux tirs au but ouais bon
lien dmi on est en vie orléans lui n'y a
plus thouars
c'est super on a gagné on a gagné en en
2001 j'ai plus de fois j'ai vu deux
voies légales et on gagne ou on gagne
hu
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit c'est pas une récompense c'est
une joie pour le club entier c'est pas
une récompense on les a eus aussi ça qui
compte on y trouve ça très bien c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'âme et lannion va fêter
ça être toute la nuit et il est assez
incroyable et on gagnera an prochain on
ira jusqu'au final on décrochera la
troupe ça c'est sûr
ça doit vouloir
c'est mission accomplie mission
accomplie pour pour les joueurs pour le
staff et pour les supporters voilà il
est bien tôt 4h30 du matin et tout le
monde tout le monde est heureux cette
qualif tout le monde est heureux aussi
de rentrer se coucher je crois et on
espère qu'il y aura de plus en plus de
monde à à montmoreau pour soutenir
l'équipe
mickaël michel responsable communication
et recrutement du club est avec nous en
visio pour nous parler de cet exploit
bonsoir michael bonsoir alors est ce que
vous êtes redescendue et un petit peu
sur terre après après cet exploit
nous projeter sur le match de
championnat qui avait lieu ce week-end
pas trop le temps de cogiter mais c'est
vrai qu'on on peut avoir quand même
encore
alors je rappelle que vous êtes
seulement le cinquième club de quatrième
division atteindre les demi finales de
l'épreuve rejoignez par exemple calais
est ce que vous réalisez
en fait peut-être pas à la hauteur de ce
que ça représente je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'on disait un petit peu avec
avec les garçons il va falloir provoquer
des semaines des mois voir certains des
années pour se rendre compte de
l'ampleur de ce qui a été fait sur sur
ces dernières semaines
encore une fois l'objectif c'est de
continuer à gagner des matches donc on
se remet vite d'eau dans le quotidien et
dans le travail qu'est ce que ça vous
fait amicale me chier de voir la place
du marché à versailles bond est heureuse
qu'est ce que ça vous fait ça ça a été
quelque chose d'exceptionnel surtout
qu'on a pu avoir les vidéos tout de
suite après la rencontre puisque
monsieur le maire était avec nous et qui
nous a gentiment montré les images de ce
qui s'était passé à versailles pendant
la rencontre et c'est vrai que ça c'est
une victoire c'est une victoire du club
d'avoir réussi à attirer une personne
pense savoir réunir autant de 4 tonnes
avec un objectif commun que vers la
qualification du club et se répand plus
ponctuelles une récompense comme la
victoire au bout bas c'est beau de voir
couper sourire de voir couper et
pillages on reçoit on a eu deux enfants
on a vu des gens aussi un pur plus âgées
on voit là le foot rassembleur dans ce
moment là c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et se sont pour une
grande fierté d'avoir participé
alors vous avez également combler les
supporters qui sont allés jusqu'à
périgueux l'était à 56 peut-être un
petit peu dans les tribunes est ce
qu'ils aient une pensée des joueurs
aussi pour penser supporters qui ont
fait sept heures de bus aller mais
également retour oui une pensée au
moment du coup final ça s'est vu puisque
les garçons se sont très vite précipités
vers eux pour fêter la qualification
mais mais sans trahir de secrets ça a
été aussi une dépense et avant le match
le coach en avait fait référence aussi
en partie donc voilà on était conscients
qu'il y avait des gens qui s'étaient
levés tôt le matin comme cela avait pu
être le cas aussi sur sur les courbes
précédent notamment à sarre-union ou à
toulouse donc voilà ça faisait partie
aussi des éléments de motivation en plus
pour le groupe pour aller chercher cette
modification au prochain tour vous allez
donc affronter un lycéen clubs de ligue
1 j'ai envie de dire enfin un club de
ligue 1 à un gros morceau
enfin une table fallu attendre jusqu'à
là jusqu'à la demi finale pour avoir en
france ce privilège là de pouvoir
fournir un club de l'élite en plus on
joue un croquis et qui est très bien
placé en championnat qui ya enfonça
l'entraîneur champion de france en titre
donc c'est une superbe but superbe de
référence donc voilà on a tenu et il
reste encore un match de championnat
encore à jouer là la semaine prochaine
avant ce match contre 11 donc cette
rencontre se disputera le mercredi 2
mars mais on ne connaît toujours pas le
lieu 1 c'est bien ça à mickaël michel
parce que le stand montbron à versailles
n'est pas homologué pour ce type de
rencontre c'est ça la certitude
effectivement comme sur plusieurs tours
maintenant c'est qu'on pourra pas avoir
la chance de jouer ce match là au stade
mont boron maintenant à l'heure actuelle
on n'a ni le lieu ni la date n'est pas
encore définie la programmation on n'a
pas non plus le
l'horaire
et minois
oui vous vous habillez sollicités
notamment le parc des princes mais le
psg dit que c'était compliqué c'est bien
ça ouais alors plus qu une sollicitation
ses bons côtés un rêve surtout pour
beaucoup de gens au club que soient les
joueurs le staff ou l'encadrement du
club de pouvoir avoir l'opportunité de
jouer cette rencontre au parc des
princes aurait été fabuleux maintenant
voilà on a on a fait le point avec le
paris saint germain c'est un grand club
avec des normes fait beaucoup
d'impératifs donc on était conscient de
toute façon que un dénouement positif
difficile pour nous mais en tout cas ils
ont été réactifs ils ont été à l'écouté
même si sa part pour ce match là mais
mais on le comprend tout à fait et il ya
aucun aucune problématique avec avec le
psg on espère peut-être que dans le
futur on aura l'opportunité de faire une
demi finale
mais ce ne sera pas pour cette saison
malheureusement ça sera forcément région
parisienne cette rencontre il ya
plusieurs pistes étudiées aujourd'hui il
ya des difficultés diverses et variées
comme en été le cas aussi sur le match
sur le match de toulouse donc voilà
aujourd'hui comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la réponse est imminente mais la
ronde d'acter ni deux idoles définitives
alors on sait que la priorité du fc
versailles 78 et le championnat à
versailles plus que jamais premier avec
la victoire de ce week-end contre poissy
à 3 à 0 mais bon on va pas se cacher
l'objectif maintenant c'est d'aller au
bout en championnat en championnat et en
coupe de france
l'attend mais les garçons sont à l'image
de nouveaux projets du club les garçons
sont des compétiteurs ambitieux donc de
toutes façons naturellement quand on
commence une compétition c'est pour
rendre au bout voilà maintenant pour
l'avenir du club effectivement la
priorité reste le championnat les gars
ont su faire preuve de beaucoup
d'abnégation pour se reconcentrer sur le
match que disputait la presse cite un
derby donc été un match pas évident ils
ont fait le boulot de manière très
propre avec une victoire large donc
voilà on a encore beaucoup de matches de
championnat qui nous attend mais mais la
priorité elle est là on aura le temps de
penser à annie ce qui est dans quelques
jours quand quand ni sera là le but
niçois radicalisme comme on l'a fait sur
surtout les tours précédents mais encore
une fois il faut pas se tromper de
bataille aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
important pour les sylvaris 30-18 d'être
en national la saison prochaine que de
remporter la coupe de france merci à
vous et à mika elle me chier on
continuera évidemment à suivre le
parcours du fc versailles 78 pour cette
coupe de france 2000 22 sur tv 78 restez
attentifs on vous prépare beaucoup de
belles choses sur notre chaîne merci me
qualifier on va continuer à parler de
versailles mais cette fois ci en rugby
dans le championnat de fédérale 3 les
versailles se sont relancés ce week-end
sur leur terrain en remportant le derby
contre roye à domicile en je leur ai mis
le faire
un derby a remporté ce dimanche 13
février versailles recevait ou au stade
mont boron pour un match en retard qui
comptait pour la dixième journée de
fédérale 3 plus solide versailles
déroule devant son public en première
période avec trois essais en poche le
score à la pause 29 à 10 de temps en
temps quand on était dans nos cinq
mètres on a tenté d'aider des jet skis
où il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
lieu de faire ces gestes là qui nous ont
fait nous retrouver dans entre entre les
perches et voilà franchement leur
rentrée elle était parfaite et une
certaine solidité défensive de leur part
aussi parce qu'ils n'ont jamais rompu on
fait une très grosse entame ce qui nous
permet vraiment de bien rentrer dans le
match qui permet un petit peu de nous
installer dans cette danse est parti on
a pris l'ascendant sur tous les duels
sur toutes les phases de conquête et de
rock donc on fait une très très bonne
entame une très bonne première mi temps
en seconde période où il revient dans le
match et bouscule les versets y est mais
les joueurs de la cité royale tiennent
bon score final 36 à 25 le bonus
offensif s'envole pour le rcv
c'est un parfait saint parfait mais on
va s'en contenter parce que en manque de
rythme depuis le début l'année ça fait
que deuxième match qu'on dispute
actuellement et voilà du coup ça se
ressent notre force que des blessés dont
c'était les trentenaires minutes et puis
la cie la claque que le club et
resserrent revient aujourd'hui donc
c'est dommage falloir qu'on repose
là-dessus ça redevient de notre force
avec ce résultat le club de verser vos
prend la tête de la poule une du
championnat de fédérale 3 wii est à la
quatrième place
on continue notre tour d'horizon des
résultats sportifs du week-end dans les
yvelines avec bixente merrion santisteva
qui nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bonsoir bixente sur michael alors on va
parler tout de suite de football et de
la nationale 3 oui c'est ça la saison
continue pour les pensionnaires aux
yvelinois de nationale 3 après un début
de saison en dents de scie le club des
mureaux n'a plus perdu depuis le 20
novembre
ça fait quand même six matchs sans
défaite avec encore une victoire ce
week-end face à linas montlhéry 3 0 le
club se rapproche donc de la première
moitié du classement avec un bilan de
cinq victoires trois nuls et six
défaites avant le prochain match est le
derby face à mantes la jolie le 27
février prochain le manteau et c'est
justement qui a fait match nul 0 0 à la
maison face à la réserve du paris saint
germain et qui est 14e qui est 10e sur
14 équipes 10 basket maintenance à jouer
du côté de poissy oui l'équipe
pisciacaise s'est imposé dans sa poule
de nationale 2
74 à 63 face au pays de fougères pour le
compte de la 17e journée avec 29 fois ci
est troisième à trois unités de la
première place partagée par les clubs
des hauts de france de longues plages et
berck à vos deux balles michel
exactement deux clubs divino à jouer la
13e journée de nationale 3 masculine ce
samedi 12 février une victoire à une
défaite michael on commence par quoi
voit la victoire la victoire plaisir qui
l'a largement emporté 37 à 20 en
bretagne face à bruce oui le vésinet
carrière de son côté a perdu 18 20 à la
maison face au club breton de morlaix
avec ces résultats les deux clubs
proposent un bilan de 7 victoires et 6
défaites et se classent respectivement à
la septième et la huitième place de la
division soit en milieu de tableau alors
bixente maintenant vous allez vous faire
voyager vous allez nous emmener à pékin
pour parler des jeux olympiques oui
exactement michael vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler de 110 clair une
ancienne cycliste sur piste qui a fait
les jeux de londres en 2012 et de rio en
2016 notamment elle a réussi sa
reconversion puisque c'est la
remplaçante de la première délégation de
bobsleigh féminin de l'histoire elle est
enfin arrivée à pékin c'était un peu
compliqué avec les différents protocoles
elle a été notamment testée positive au
co vide elle a dû attendre avant de
pouvoir valider son test négatif est de
rejoindre tout récemment ces derniers
jours la délégation française on a pu
suivre un peu ces contretemps c'est des
régions sur ces réseaux notamment et son
soulagement d'être arrivé merci
félicitations à elle sandie clair sera
donc remplaçant de l'équipe de bobsleigh
féminin qui entrera prochainement en
lice à pékin on termine par une petite
touche technique à bixente exactement à
défaut de voir son équipe l'emporter
face à versailles le maire pisciacais
karl olive s'est essayé à la lucarne
d'evry vous en avez déjà entendu parler
et michael oui je me suis pas encore
essayé mais je vais tenter un jour qu'on
a hâte de voir la vidéo en tout cas
c'est devenu un sanctuaire du football
cette petite lucarne qu'il faut
atteindre du premier coup dans le
quartier des pyramides d'evry beaucoup
de personnalités s'y sont essayés
dans le milieu du football notamment le
marocain bénatia l'ancien joueur du
paris saint germain nenê même lionel
messi a été mis en scène avec pour une
pub eh bien il était temps pour le fan
de football qui est karl olive de s'y
essayer regardez sa tentative
mal à s que le mur et a distant il
existe en service
alors on y va et que deux écoles est ok
ryad la culture
[Rires]
voilà donc comme le dit si bien car le
livre plat du pied efficacité plat du
pied sécurité mitaine toujours bravo à
karl olive et je tiens à noter quand
même qu'il est en chaussures de ville 1
ce qui rend la tâche encore plus
compliquée bravo à karl olive merci me
chantait en tout cas pour toutes ces
précisions on retrouve la semaine
prochaine on va maintenant prendre la
direction du vélotour national de saint
quentin en yvelines après deux ans
d'absence le championnat ile-de-france
de l'omnium était programmé ce dimanche
13 février pendant toute la journée au
total une centaine de sportifs ont
répondu présents pour ce rendez vous qui
compte quatre épreuves sur la même
journée un événement organisé par le
vélo club de montigny le bretonneux on
écoute son président
dans l'ensemble il ya un très bon niveau
à partir des juniors seniors parce que
là c'est des coureurs confirmés qui ont
déjà couru et c'est là la plus grosse
interrogation chez au point au niveau
des minimes et des cadets où
pratiquement ce sont tous des débutants
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu d'organisation
pendant deux ans
toujours en cyclisme sur piste il est de
retour aux affaires après avoir mis un
terme à sa carrière en janvier à 2021
l'yvelinois grégory baugé quadruple
médaillé olympique va devenir entraîneur
de l'équipe nationale de sprint à
compter du mois de mars il était choisi
par le nouveau directeur du programme
olympique florian rousseau il aura pour
objectif de faire briller la france aux
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024 il
entraînera donc les sportifs au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines on va maintenant par les
baskets et d'un match particulièrement
attendu le 17 février les lycée
sainte-geneviève et hoche de versailles
vont s'affronter sur un match de basket
l'événement est très attendue par les
étudiants des deux structures à montage
jerry janin un match de basket avec des
étudiants chauffé à blanc dans une salle
pleine à craquer après deux ans
d'absence le sulfureux derby ginette
auch sera de retour le 17 février
prochain ce rendez vous entre les deux
lycées versailles a été imaginé par
françois allaman professeur de sport au
lycée sainte-geneviève j'ai créé et un
petit match entre élèves à 10 personnes
dans un gymnase 2004 et petit à petit ça
a pris de l'ampleur quelque chose en
plus quelques enceinte en plus 300 500
800 900 personnes et après on est parti
sur mont boron pour une machine
importante aujourd'hui l'événement
regroupe plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
sur une soirée au gymnase mot bron avec
en jeu bien plus qu'un match le basket
mais une suprématie c'est un oxford
cambridge pardonnez moi c'est référence
à la sauce nba
sur deux entités qui se connaissent
depuis des dizaines voire plus années et
qui ont envie ce moment-là de de
participer à une grande joute sportive
basket le spectacle sera également
autour du terrain au programme des shows
de pom pom girls un dj ou encore des vip
dans les tribunes c'est une folle
ambiance qui surprend même les joueurs
de l'équipe de france qui sont venus de
basket ça n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans
le milieu professionnel et c'est ce qui
nous surprend tous encore chaque année
le match est uniquement sur invitation
pour les spectateurs venus de
l'extérieur pour l'instant ginette
domine ce dernier avec 14 victoires pour
une seule défaite
c'est la fin cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]